les liaisons dangereuses de choderlos de
laclos sont on le sait mais répétons le
un chef-d'oeuvre un chef-d'oeuvre qui
hante aussi les cinéastes aussi que
milos forman signe à son tour une
nouvelle adaptation brillante plus
original que les précédentes
le titre du film qui sort demain dans
les salles valmont nom du séducteur bien
sûr nicolas cornu langlois une trés
somptueuse et fidèle reconstitution
historique du xviiie siècle
l'affrontement entre l'innocence et la
décadence l'idéalisme et le cynisme des
personnages ambigus et passionné qui
joue avec le mal
madame de merteuil charmeuse et pulpeuse
un vicomte de valmont élégant et
arrogant madame de tourvel lucide
aimante et les très jeunes d'ancenis et
cécile de volanges ce sont les atouts
qui ont séduit cet américain d'adoption
tchèque d'origine et de coeur qui doit
cette découverte littéraire à milan
kundera fait beaucoup beaucoup de
français parmi les liaisons dangereuses
c'était génial s'il n'a pas vraiment
expliqué la littérature il a troqué
enthousiasme
il l'a fait il a parlé des choses d'une
façon qui nous a fait courir à la maison
et prendre le livre de lemire sans nous
dire comment le lit c'est de mon avis
c'était
très mal an et comment avez vous avec
jean claude carrière adapter ce
mécanisme du roman épistolaire
on sait seulement de ses personnages
qu'ils ont voulu y virent aux autres
personnages mais comment était en dehors
de l'être c'est pas là alors on a essayé
de délits mais qu'est ce qui se passait
vraiment avant que la lettre est écrit
j'ai toujours rêvé de pouvoir vomi
jamais réussi alors milos forman a fait
un film dédié à valmy mais ce sont
surtout les femmes qui ont la parole
la force et le pouvoir c'est n'importe
quoi